Charles Bukowski said that love is a fog
that burns away with the first daylight
of reality I love that quote uh do you
think romantic love Fades away in this
way Makowski uh does it does it have to
fade the truth is that you have all of
these chemicals pumping through your
body you're essentially high on heroin
in the beginning of a romance and you're
going to have these rose-colored glasses
on everything your partner does is
magical and but really it's the novelty
it's just like going on a vacation
you're fully present you're just attuned
to the magic of another human being
moment to moment and then on top of that
you have you're just flooded with
dopamine so you're high on drugs and we
can't go on like that you will die if
you are using these kinds of chemicals
all the time all day long so eventually
our bodies are sort of made to dial it
down we've made it I mean we're
evolutionary beings we are doing the
same thing we did 200 000 years ago to
find a mate procreate spend enough time
with each other that we have sex on
whole bunch of times and make babies
now we've changed the rules of the game
we're living you know almost until we're
100 years old in some cases we're making
these marriage commitments that last
half a century and uh we're expecting it
to be all because of love and we're
signing these contracts based on how we
feel when we're high on these drugs so
the reality is we know based on the re
and and I'm also talking about certain
Western civilizations here because as
you know there are arranged marriages
and a lot of times those marriages if
we're looking at longevity are actually
way more satisfied than people who are
marrying for love which logically makes
sense if you're making a decision based
on a feeling that is basically based on
endorphins and dopamine and oxytocin
I wouldn't sign a contract just because
of a feeling necessary you know for 50
years whereas an arranged marriage if
you have your elders kind of deciding
for you that this partner has a bunch of
traits that you're going to appreciate
more and more over time
I think there's some wisdom there so you
don't think that feeling could be a
foundation for a 50-year relationship
well I don't think that specific feeling
you're having based on drugs is going to
be the same feeling you have 20 30 40
years down the line if you're going to
wake up and turn to your partner when
you're 70 and think oh my God I'm so
glad you're hot you are so hot yeah then
sure marry for hotness but if you've
been through life a little bit and I
think most people who are on a second
marriage know happens in life it is
hard you're gonna have you know maybe a
kid with special needs or your dad gets
Dementia or you get diagnosed with
cancer who are you going to want to come
home to who is going to hold you when
you are sobbing on the floor and tell
you we're going to get through it
together who's going to know the names
of your kids special ed teacher and the
process for getting a 504 plan or is it
going to be you on your own I think
those things matter but doesn't that
hotness don't those drugs kind of
solidify into a deeper appreciation of
the other person
into something you could call Beauty yes
uh they can but but isn't that the same
isn't that the same thing when you know
when you notice the beauty of another
human being aren't you aren't you high
on drugs still you're making it sound
like there's like a a brief rock star
period of going on heroin and then it's
over but like can she be on heroin your
whole life I have some good news
that was something I think one of the
reasons I got into studying
relationships was because I wanted that
right so I'm a scientist but I also love
art and I love writing and I love
literature I wanted to know that true
love could be real but as a scientist I
am cynical I just need some data and
when so I practice the type of therapy
called the gottman method and I love
that because it tends to be well it is
one of the most evidence-based therapies
we have based on John and Julie gottman
two psychologists who have been
researching relationships for now about
50 years and this therapy happens to be
for couples they found that you
absolutely can make longevity work in a
relationship you can build you are not
just settling for companionship but you
can have passion and intimacy and
growing love and appreciation but there
is a blueprint a set of skills that we
were never given we're not taught in
school we changed the rules of the game
and we haven't learned the rules yet
and uh the goblin method for couples
therapy kind of gives you a few
guidelines the rules for longevity in a
relationship yeah they did a beautiful
job at taking these findings they had
through you know Decades of research
quantifying it and then codifying it
into a therapy method it's really skills
based I tell couples when they're
starting out with me that they're
essentially going to be starting a class
so what's the five to one Golden Rule
what I read is there's the kind of
balance you can achieve of
uh how many interactions you have in a
relationships that are positive versus
negative and I think that's what the
five to one means but basically there
should be a kind of an empirical
like if you just look back over over a
month how many of the interactions were
positive for the day or the day
right so the the idea of this ratio
um well it's not an idea it was a
finding it is uh research finding that
the gotmans got after looking at
thousands of couples
um and codifying these interactions that
they were observing couples that tend to
be satisfied in their relationships
um that are happier they have better
health Etc they are having approximately
five positive interactions to each
negative and I want to be clear about
what I'm defining as positive and
negative here so this doesn't
necessarily mean that you're these don't
need to be big sweeping romantic
gestures buying flowers having sex these
are things like paying attention to what
we call your partner's bids we make
these bids for affection for connection
all the time in our relationships not
just with our partners but with our
friends our co-workers and we may not
even know what our style a bit is but if
you see them on a sheet you can pretty
quickly identify them bids could be
wanting to show your partner tell your
partner something and have them be proud
of you it could be wanting to go buy
groceries with your partner doing things
together hey you want to come with me it
could be telling a joke and hoping that
your wife looks up from her email on the
computer and acknowledges it if she
laughs then you've got a positive but if
I don't even look up that's a negative
right so it's not necessarily that I'm
calling my husband an it's just
am I connecting with him am I meeting
those bids for connection and vice versa
well do those also give you a guide of
how you should behave
well I think what's really important is
actually asking your partner or paying
attention to what your partner's bids
are because what matters to Ty my
husband may not matter to you for
instance I mean Ty's bar is so low with
me I thank God what defines a positive
interaction right like he just wants me
to ask him if he wants a water when I
get up to get myself one just be a basic
decent considerate person is all he asks
of me whereas mine might be sort of like
stay up later with me watch a show
um go to bed at the same time as me or
um know about the people in my life that
sort of a thing I should highlight this
and I hope hopefully it's okay that you
were running a little bit late and you
send me this text which is which people
do really rarely and there's a subtle
act of kindness within that text so the
the you the text you sent was that um I
just decreased the amount of stress in
your life or something like this by
saying it's good it's cool but that
means that you were you're you're
signaling that you were stressed because
you care enough to be there on time and
that was like that made me feel really
special I was like oh you know people
don't know people don't often don't
always do that because that puts you
also that makes you vulnerable
vulnerable and I actually thought that
after I sent it but I feel that most of
the day any interaction like oh God I
just exposed myself but absolutely I was
excited to be here and I didn't want you
to think that I didn't care
I think being a therapist has shown me
that it really it's so lucky to be in
that position because you meet people
that you would have thought are cooler
than you or smarter than you or just
somehow impervious to life and you
realize that we are all in it together
we all want to be cared about and liked
we don't want to be liked as a baseline
I some people will say they don't care
but everybody does it's human and I have
gotten much better being a therapist
much more comfortable showing caring
showing love and genuineness and
vulnerability than I think I ever would
have been otherwise and that kind of
vulnerability is what's required to do a
positive interaction in a relationship I
think so and and people have different
levels of comfort right so
um but as long as it's working for both
partners and typically you have to
communicate to figure out what your
partner what makes your partner feel
cared about however you might be working
for instance with an older couple and I
have a a couple that's perfectly happy
and they sort of have a system it works
for them if there's some sort of a
rupture if they get into some sort of a
disagreement they don't talk it out she
might go to the store run an errand
doing do a little shopping he'll work in
the wood shop and then they'll come back
and there is a repair attempt though but
it's maybe she'll say hey do you want to
have dinner or come you know I made your
favorite dinner and or he'll say hey I
recorded your favorite show you want to
watch it tonight so they don't need to
process it but there is an understanding
between them that we're still in this
together we care about each other and
there's a repair attempt
most people need to be able to process
it verbally and talk about what happened
not all so for most people if there's a
conflict you should talk about and
resolve it and repair it versus like
just put it behind you yeah I I don't
want to say should I guess it depends on
the couple yeah everybody processes
emotions differently everybody handles
emotional expression differently I mean
I have couples where I have one person
in the partnership who has autism and
the other doesn't and so they're
obviously going to have different ways
of communicating or processing what
happened we all have different
perspectives it really depends on what
makes a person feel like it's been
repaired what makes a person feel
understood does that need to be verbal
or in the case of that older couple I
have where they know they understand one
another because there's a gentleness
toward one another after